[Music]  it's over I think it's just getting  started  [Music]  we killed someone  self-defense  [Music]  ever since Jake ran off to Mexico Murder  Club have been looking extremely guilty  so we all got the same message Simon  Says do what I say or everyone will know  what you did  we have to figure out what Simon Says is  and until then we need to do whatever  they say  they're blackmailing us oh my God  what the hell are you two doing River  Simon Says is they're getting more  Twisted so you're actually going through  is this what does this psycho want  wow  we have to put an end to this  you are making a big mistake  there's been so many lies did you tell  anybody  about Jake since he disappeared  [Music]  I think it's time  for the truth  [Music]  [Music]